insidious part tucker he was submitted  to and he did submit to some type of  brainwashing i mean they have made all  of these january 6th defendants  essentially repent from any beliefs they  ever had and echo critical race theory  ideas read the right books and tell a  judge they apologize for everyone and  everything they've ever been it's it's  really gross and it's a violation of due  process and it's just a violation of our  sense of justice now i don't know if the  references to gandhi or whatever were  part of that i'm not really sure but  that's what we might call an alternative  perspective and that's actually  something that's being repeated a lot by  the right which is these  uh  alleged insurrectionists are not only  being treated unfairly some of them by  being kept detained in pre-trial  detention they're not allowed out on  bail or they can't afford it um they're  also being brainwashed  as the case is against them or going  forward okay